that wasn't even in an epsilon
neighborhood of what i said i have some
problems some of which have existing
solutions that are inadequate some of
which don't have existing solutions and
many of which like one or two involved
cloud computing but but not all of them
the important takeaway though is if you
have problems you want to bring up or
I'll just sort of war that's that's
supposed to be a warm-up for open
questions and then I'm going to sir turn
turn into the moderator okay if you've
seen this talk before let me recommend
the coffee and pastries outside I with
an audience that hasn't seen me talk
before I like to start with why I left
the university since many of you are
university students or faculty and why
I'm happier and happier having left the
university this is an email i received
from the Texas Higher Education
Coordinating Committee which actually
runs the entire University of Texas
System your last name is your password
if you had to have any questions or
you've forgotten your password please
contact the Coordinating Board so having
left the university I thought I would
get away from this kind of thing but
here's a form i had to fill out at a
previous employer type in your name
notice also the self need not answer the
question below okay i'm going to talk
about a lot of papers in this in this
i'm going to i'm going to breeze through
a bunch of papers partly i'm doing that
because i started out with an idea about
applying machine learning and input in
particular applying active exploration
to to make search results or search
advertising better and then just to kind
of really encourage you to go for that
coffee now I kind of in the end go
through a process by which I come full
circle and prove joint with paprika
will prove a theorem that says
everything I thought I was supposed to
be doing was wrong and so and in fact
now I've gone from being like a strong
proponent of active learning to being
against active learning and so that's
the thumbnail about what this is about
okay so here's the plan I want to talk
about advertising thanks to Paul I don't
have to do that very much because I'm
mostly going to be talking about display
advertising which he able introduced
I'll talk about one of the early papers
we wrote on this topic which we call the
machine learners curse and then I'm
going to talk about the value of
learning by which I mean active
exploration so that is to say trying to
bring active exploration into the
pricing of the auctions themselves to
make it more optimal okay so Paul's
already drawn this distinction between
performance ads or search ads and
display ads some estimates hold the
display ads are on the order of a sixty
billion dollar business in contrast to
Paul's distinction many of those ads are
actually run as performance in the sense
of the advertisers only pay when a click
occurs but what's important here is that
some are in some art is that there's
some of both operating simultaneously
and generally you rank ads by the
probability of a click x the bid that's
a expected impression value to do that
we have to estimate a click-through rate
and that's where machine learning comes
in a big scale machine learning and
there are I also want to say that
advertisers use a lot of targeting
features so that is to say they can the
its typically visible to an advertiser
the demographics may be inferred from
history location actually they get me to
a set of four houses that is to say when
I go look myself up and say where is my
IP address it actually narrows it down
to
for houses it doesn't get me exactly but
pretty close interest you can get by
time on a web page characteristics and
and what time of day day of the week and
so on are all available so we're going
to estimate the cliq probability and
give this impression value which is a
bid times the probability of a click and
the payment that's we're going to only
focus on second price auction so this
payment is the second highest bid x the
cliq probability for the second highest
bid / the quick probability associated
with the highest impression value as i
mentioned there's lots of targeting so
here's some of the things you might be
able to do target on we maybe have a
flash ad that's got a specific size it
we know that it's a 45 between 40 and 45
year old woman who's in Fort Smith
Arkansas she's married and has young
children at least judged by the website
she visits which we have in a cookie we
know something about family income may
be from demographics United States at
the nine digit zip code we're a very
homogeneous country in terms of our
demographics or at least in terms of
income we know some interests again
judge by websites what page she's on
right at the moment and what is the day
which happens to be Valentine's Day in
this example and I actually have a
picture of her here's this woman she's
on she's asked which of the following is
the largest and she picks the elephant
over the moon and this is going to dog
her for the rest of her life and Here I
am making that worse so what one of the
things that's really impressive is the
way these systems perform that is the
engineering of these and so in somewhere
around a quarter of a second so you go
visit CNN CNN sends a call to an to an
ad auction site looking for an ad to put
on that page and it so there's going to
be a call from the page that's going to
that call involved
passing over characteristics which are
things like the demographics and cookies
and so on that we talked about there
maybe add restrictions and so on all
that stuff has to be sent from the web
page and from there it goes out to the
bidders the bidders and there could be
40,000 of them the bidders then have to
compute a bid based on all that
information they compute bids those bids
come back click probabilities are then
assessed they may be bidding based on a
click or bidding based on an action such
as filling in a web form so click
probabilities have to be estimated for
both of those kinds we need to sort the
bids well enough to get the top one and
the second highest one because we're
going to suck a price it so we need to
get both of those pull the ad from the
database this by the way is the single
slowest feature of all this stuff is
often what adds time and when you're
sitting there on a web page waiting for
an ad to load because they won't show
you the content until the ad loads
mostly this is the culprit is that
pulling the ad from the database because
the advertisers use some really crummy
company we then send the add to the web
page and then offline we have to account
for the payment and any fees that are
associated with it and then this we're
going to do all of this stuff and turn
around in some cases only got a dollar
per thousand ads those those part that
price is a little bit low now they're
little bit faster obviously what we
don't have is a crowdsource solution
where there are a bunch of people in
India or turkey filling these out or
Ohio actually is that is the most the
median Mechanical Turk so what's the
machine learners curse well here's the
thing we've got a prediction and that
prediction happens with error they are
not error-free in fact even after
hundreds of thousands of ad runs you
will still have errors associated with
the with the predictions well the fact
that we've got predictions and we have
the probability of a click in the
denominator is already bad
worse still but when we over predict bid
x click probability is higher we're more
likely to win the auction if we under
predict and specifically if I predict
that the cliq probability is 0 you will
lose the auction by predict your clicker
probability is 0 if I predict your cliq
probability is high you'll win the
auction it is the winner's curse the ads
about which we over predict are more
likely to win it as a result if I'm
pitting an ad that I don't have to make
the prediction because it's a payment by
impression against an ad where I have to
make a prediction it's a payment by
click I'm going to favor the payments by
clicks that is I'm going to
disadvantaged the ads where I didn't
have to make a prediction we're still my
over predictions are likely to be I have
less I have more noise in the system
when I predict actions versus clicks
that is actions like filling in a web
page or buying something as a result the
the variance tends to be higher on those
and this effect is even more extreme now
all of it goes away right in principle
as I learn the cliq probabilities the
machine learning system gets better it
gets measurably better you know more or
less daily so in principle that goes
away this effect goes away in practice
it does not and the reason is over time
old data gets becomes useless so we
deprecate old data in favor of new data
there are if I show a movie ad it'll get
a lot of clicks three weeks later it
doesn't get any clicks the data from the
initial clicks gets bad that the amount
by which dated appreciates is kind of on
the order of let's say one to five
percent per day goes away pretty quickly
yes statistical globes here
it's not clear to me not say unbiased
estimators are good or minimizing wins
for terrorists you like what is the
objective you know in this application
right so i actually to fit this in the
time the session the section i with i
rejected was the loss function section
the loss functions that are chosen which
are either maximum likelihood or square
squared error are chosen but for
convenience they're not chosen because
they actually represent the problem so
clear yes so so there is a there i have
a paper on this which i'll take off line
which the joint with patrick hummel
which says here's the lost function you
should be using for this problem and to
make the estimation better it's not
clear that it actually makes it a lot
better by the way that is to say the the
bad news is is that even though it may
be optimal it's actually not that much
better the second thing I'll say is is
that even with the winners curse there's
a fix for this and in principle we could
use the same fix but the problem here is
we would we need an estimate of the
variance now that's what's the variance
of our predictions and that's a hard
thing to know and the reason it's a hard
thing to know is if I do these
estimations that say with a logistic
regression with somewhere between 100
million and a billion right hand side
variables with a billion right hand side
variables I've got a mate by variance
covariance matrix as a matrix that's a
billion by a billion which is already
going to strain your system just storing
it much less computing it we're still I
got to invert that matrix by the way
when we get around to the session on
Thursday remember that okay so one thing
that that every machine learner will
tell you is that you should do active
learning that is to say you should say I
want to actually understand
and this the world I live in so let me
give you the example of I have let's say
we've corrected the previous problem the
machine learners curse we've already
corrected that problem so now i have a
bid for an impression of a penny and i
have a price per click Add whose
impression value that's bid times the
probability of a click is also a penny
so it's a dead heat it's a tie in that
world I should always pick the price per
impression and run that and the reason
is if I run the if i take the impression
out i don't learn anything I didn't
learn anything at all I ran the ad no
one we were looking for a click there
was it a click there wasn't any news
there's no news I run the ad the price
per click Add and either i gather click
or I don't either way that's data the
data goes into the machine learning
system the machine learning system gets
better so I have in addition to the
penny that I expected assuming I'd fix
the earlier problem i have i learned
something from running that ad not very
much tiny tiny amount but I learned
something so that's what i mean by the
value of learning i should incorporate
that into the auction that is to say i
have this at this ad which I don't learn
anything from or maybe I've run it maybe
it's a per click Add but I've run it
four billion times and so it's AT&T and
so actually they ran 95 million ads in a
year and so I've already run this 95
billion sorry three orders of magnitude
off 95 billion ads in one year so I have
that add that I don't learn anything
about I have this other ad that I've
only run once it's valuable to learn I
would like to incorporate that into the
auction just the the that how much I'm
going to learn has value okay I want to
now give you a different perspective
that comes about from thinking about
exchanges which is to say usually the
way machine learners what would approach
this problem is they'd say what action
should I take and pick the action that
is
say it's based on think of the old style
as an array of one-armed bandits and I'm
asking which are my should take to give
a different perspective on that which is
now I have an auction what I want to ask
is which bid should i submit to that
auction should i submit a how much so i
could just submit the advertisers bid or
i could perturb the bid if i don't like
this advertiser for one reason i could
decrease their bid or if i like them i
could promote them very much what Paul
talked about with his alpha are going to
make it easier or harder for some
bidders to win and that's going to then
incorporate the value of learning the
value that the system gets out of
learning so the efficient bid in fact is
just the immediate value we're going to
get plus the value of learning think
about this an impression space and then
we can do the adjustment on the click to
do clicks okay the thing that I didn't
take into account at first and where
we're going to end just so there's a
saying that that you know if you're a
magician and you want to pull a rabbit
out of the Hat it isn't very impressive
if I show you a hat and they're like
ears sticking out to begin with ok this
is the ears sticking out is that what
what is different about auctions from
the rest of machine learning
applications or from other machine
learning applications is that the
auctions are actually going to give us a
fair bit of free exploration and when we
take that into account the value of x of
exploration is going to be is going to
be different it's going to be lower ok
one thing it's that's kind of an aside
but it's something that I got very
obsessed with is is that exploring has
externalities and let me just give the
example that I've got a Toyota ad and
I've got the website car and driver and
I run that and that's got various
features it's got features like
automobile on it on the page and if I
run that ad I learned stuff
not just about Toyota ads on car and
driver but it spills over so they're
externalities when I when I when I'm go
to run a Nissan ad on road and track the
the on the road and track website I've
learned something from the other ad now
when I'm faced with the problem of
externalities what I might want to do is
subsidized the first ad because I'm
going to get benefits later and what you
might imagine and this would be kind of
in some sense the the the optimal thing
to do is to say let's just keep track of
all that let's keep track of where we
learned and put subsidies in to account
for the benefits that we get later in
the system okay from a engineering
perspective airy nice from an economics
perspective and from an engineering
perspective it's madness because it
winds up being such a large space and
moreover it puts me in the position
where let's say I ran this Toyota ad on
the car driver website and what I
learned is nobody clicked on it and then
later I'm thinking about running in this
on ad on the road and track website and
i say i'm going to charge road and track
to not run than this on that and maybe I
charge Nissan as well because I learned
earlier that that ad didn't work or is
unlikely to work that is I'm going to
charge somebody to not do something
because I've now learned that it didn't
work only I'm not going to do anything
for them and so they're going to look at
that as being a completely arbitrary and
capricious charge this is a different
version of the value of learning I don't
know why they didn't come up there it is
this is if also from Fort Smith where
our woman was before not literally
you're supposed to do the math here
Arkansas turns out to be the only state
in the united states that requires
algebra two of its high school students
and now you understand why okay okay so
what this gives us though if we're going
to try to build in the value of learning
is
is that when I'm faced with running an
ad I get an immediate value which has
the gobbledygook name the expected cost
per impression which is actually cost
per thousand impressions in the actual
the M is actually a thousand although
that would have been k so I don't know
why but let's say it's cost per
impression is the expected value so I
have some expected value thinking about
it as a dynamic program i'm going to add
to that value the value of learning
whatever the whatever I expect I will
learn from running this ad which is
going to be high on ads that have
features I haven't seen very much so I
don't know very much about those
features and it's going to be low on
other features and then I'm going to
just second price this animal so that is
to say i'm going to pick the ad with the
highest social value that's bi and i'm
going to charge a value which is just
that it's the lowest amount they could
bid and still be in the high high social
value right i'm going to second price
that animal and that winds up with the
second height i'm going to charge the
second highest value plus the difference
in the value of learning and that's all
incentive compatible and that all works
and you can actually so one thing that
goes wrong with this right off the bat
is it could give you negative prices but
we can fix that just by putting a
reserve which is a we're never going to
we're never going to pay you to run your
ad what we will just zero that out okay
so that's the general the general
thought now that in itself has the
property that sometimes I charge
advertisers that well let me put it this
way initially I'm probably going to lose
money because I'm going to run ads with
a high value of learning and I'm going
to have a lower a lower amount and and
why should i charge the advertiser that
amount why should the advertiser be
paying well this is this
toyota problem is now I'm going to you
know sometimes I'm going that the
sometimes the car driver is going to get
less money because there was this
negative net value of learning so
sometimes i'm going to give less money
to car and driver and the benefits are
going to accrue to somebody else and
what that suggests is can we split those
because after all the value of learning
is a social value not a private value
it's a value to the system not a value
to the individual website so can I split
those in apart where I'm going to charge
the advertiser the net the second the
second price socha of the social value
so that is the same going to charge the
advertiser this amount but I'm going to
pay that amount that is to say I'm going
to pay the second highest immediate
value and slip those apart we call that
a learning account and so the idea is
now I'm going to divorce payments from
from divorce the payments from the
amount that i pay out as the advertiser
payments from the amount that i pay out
this will be a relationship between them
of course but they won't be necessarily
the same thing because i'm going to pay
websites based on the what they would
get if i ran a greedy auction and i'm
going to charge the advertisers the
socially the social second price and the
question that it is is that does that
lose money or not so let me also say
there's another reason why I have to why
I might want to divorce these two which
is if i'm paying websites less money
they may want to say I'm just not going
to take new ads I'm not going to take
ads until I've seen them you know I have
a vetting process where new ads which
are the ones with high value of learning
typically new ads won't be allowed to
run for six months let somebody else pay
the learning costs on the new ads
that could actually make you more money
under this system if I'm charging if I'm
making the publishers bear the learning
costs is that and and since publishers
have a legitimate reason to not run a
new ads because maybe those ads are
obnoxious and let me prove that and this
is actually something that sometimes
really stresses my computer these are
seven of the ten most obnoxious ads on
the web as judged by Amazon Mechanical
Turk this is taking a while to get
running and actually this one what's
funny is the Turkish said what they
really hate about this ad is what does a
giraffe have to do with mortgage rates
is that it just makes no sense it wasn't
that it was like obnoxious like this ad
or that ad it was just that it made no
sense it was irritating because it made
no sense to continue with obnoxious ads
this is one of those ones when you've
seen it it's really hard to kind of
unring that Bell it's got an evil of me
really to show you that ad like what
were they thinking is this really going
to sell more pork but it's a and then
this one is not so much it's really just
bad ad placement as opposed to the top
that's a bad ad necessarily but you
might see why a publisher says I don't
want to run new ads there's some bad ads
out there and the fact that there are
bad ads out there gives a publisher
cover for set for rejecting new ads
which are the ones where they would get
less money that's a problem resolved by
running a learning account where we
where we where we pay publishers the
immediate expected second price that is
what they would have gotten if we
followed the greedy strategy and we run
instead a but instead we charge a
different amount and we hope we make
enough money now why should you think
that we would make enough money well
there's definitely enough money in the
system if we're doing the efficient
level of exploration we're producing
more value
and we would have without the efficient
level of exploration that's in some
sense the definition of the efficient
level of exploration is the one that
produces the maximum value so there's
enough social resources to pay for this
the question is can we actually extract
them and what's a fact not in evidence
is that there's enough in the second
price auction right you know first price
auction where we could see everybody's
values there's automatically almost by
definition enough value but in the
second price not so much okay so what
we're going to pay the publishers the
second price we're going we're going to
charge the advertisers the second social
value and then we're going to charge the
difference of those things which by the
way is not necessarily the same number
is this and the reason is the second
highest eCPM that is immediate value
doesn't have to be the same ad is the
second highest social value and in fact
often won't be so this too is not the
same as the second value in the
advertisers unfortunately would have
been a lot easier if that were true so
so then the question is do we make
enough money let me actually just
illustrate this is up there mainly
because I can do it rather than any
rather than any so what's going on here
is therefore different ads indicated by
their colors these are their actual
expected values these are the second
highest are the highest social value so
what you see here is at this point the
blue ad appears to be best that's
because we're overestimating its click
probability and for that and so the blue
ad runs its second price down here
and then at some point we start learning
about the blue add it dips down below
actually it's still running here here
all of a sudden we start running the
purple ad it's dipped down below the
purple Adam we start running the purple
ad and then we learn about that and this
system then second prices we were going
to second price the social value which
looks a lot like upper confidence bound
learning works very much like upper
confidence bounding here's the same
thing with lots and lots of ads this is
running ten thousand impressions this is
too slow to watch so let's just speed it
up and what one thing that you see and
actually we can see we can see this here
is these guys almost by definition
converge that is to say the high value
that the social value for the top ad has
to be approximately equal to the social
value for the second highest ad why
because if they're different will keep
running the top ad and will keep
learning about it and the value of
learning for that ad will tend to fall
until it's equal to the second ad and
because of that there can be enough
money this is actually the cumulative
net learning account this is a pretty
typical picture even though it's just
one run so it's the run associated with
the one I just showed you which is to
say we lose a lot of money initially
while we learn a lot as the learning
stabilizes the we start actually making
money in here we're actually making two
percent now this eventually goes to zero
eventually the pre and these by the way
are the fraction of revenue so this is
two percent of revenue notice that we
lost six percent of revenue so here's
what I got to with this when when we
actually got this completed this work
was do you think we could sell the
management on losing six percent so that
will eventually make money sometime in
the future any guesses on that no yeah
I'm not not even close and good does
that turned out not to be the right way
to think about it so let me say we think
of that is actually a solution that
would buy
the way we have a theorem it's got quite
limited has had a lot of hypotheses so
it's not that interesting of a theorem
that says in the limit you can actually
pay for this even in the second price
auction the so where we went to next is
there are some experiments with active
learning the experiments turn out
terribly I ran one when I was at Yahoo
actually we ran this experiment it was
the it was the penultimate launch of
Yahoo search so that is to say we they
had one set of experiments then they had
one more set that which included ours
they had one more set of experiments and
then they outsourced to Microsoft so we
barely got this in when we run these
experiments with active learning to see
can we actually make more money by by
being intentional in our exploration the
answers typically no it's either a tiny
tiny amount like one-tenth of a percent
or less or it's even zero or negative
and so these experiments don't typically
work that well and the answer the reason
for that turns out to be that that when
you say how much exploration should
there be answers not much okay so let me
put this in put a little notation up
we've got an ad with an uncertain value
it's got a tight that's not observed
we've run it k times this can all be
translated into feature space but I'm
going to tell the story without features
to make it simpler so it's got an
uncertain click rate that's gotta mean
and a variance actually you're never
going to need this notation but the
thing to notice is the variance is / as
you'd expect is divided by the number of
impressions you've run it it's all
allowed to evolve with time this is like
the movies which depreciate over time
because people have already seen the ads
otherwise we're not worried about time
and we've got some alternative add that
we could run so that is to say there's
an ad with some distribution which is
our best competing ad is the setting
that we're in so that gives us a loss
function which is to say some of the
time we
on this ad when it's worse than the
alternative and some of the at time we
run so if we run the if we if we choose
a critical value Z some of the time
we're going to run this ad when we
should have run the other add some of
the time we're going to run the the
other AD when we should have run this ad
because we've underestimated it all of
that comes up with a with a loss
function and so you can now think of
they comes up with a loss function for
what the critical value is so the first
thing which I think we've already seen
I'm going to skip how much time if I got
Bobby this is great so I'm posing this
as a dynamic programming problem which
is to say I'm going to choose the
critical value that I use as I'm going
to run this ad when the best alternative
ad is worse than some critical value Z
and otherwise I'm going to run the best
alternative ad so this is the loss
function associated with that when the
truth of this ad is in this form that is
it's the mean plus some error and the
and the critical value i use dizzy ok
and so so and then what happens when I
run that ad is I get this extra kick i
get i now have run the ad k plus 1 times
where i had run at k times and so that's
going to give me an improvement in my in
my value function and these things are
functions of really long arguments that
are hidden and delta is the discount
factor and so this is what our present
the value of the dynamic program turns
out to look like and that's what I so
that's what I want to maximize is the
maximum value I want to choose the
critical value that maximizes the payoff
of the ad running the ad and that gives
me something I pointed out before but
here's the notation for it the critical
value i use is the immediate value i get
plus the discounted value of my
improvement in the dynamic program and
that this this term here is the
value of learning that's the value of
learning term in the dynamic prop
dynamic program okay what we do then is
take limits for relatively large K and
I'll talk a little bit about what
happens with smaller k and the first
thing to note is that the value is on
the order of 1 over this value of
learning term is it best that of the
dynamic program for the value is on the
order of 1 over K and not just because
the variance is 1 over the number of
times I've run it so as a consequence
that difference in the value is on the
order of 1 over K squared okay so that
is how much i'm increasing my bid to
account for the value of learning falls
as the square of the number of
impressions how often does that matter
well it matters on proportional to the
size of the change so those if I
increase my bid most of the time that
doesn't make any difference some of the
time it makes a difference how much it
how often it matters it makes a
difference is again also on the order of
the of the square so that is to say the
efficiency gain associated with using
active learning over the greedy strategy
Falls is the fourth power it dissipates
really quickly so what this says is if
you if you if you compare the greedy
strategy against the greedy strategy
mean just maximize whatever is the
present value and ignore learning which
is what we do today by and large against
learning that they converge to each
other really quickly and so instead if
you did something ad-hoc like say okay
if I've got a new ad I'm going to
explore it a hundred times and then
after that i'll just use whatever is the
expected value I'll maximize the
expected the immediate value to i'll
follow the greedy strategy you don't go
very far wrong
because it's on the order of 1 over a
hundred to the fourth upper confidence
bounding adds a term which is
proportional to 1 over the square root
this is the logic is is that this is
adding a standard deviation term so I'm
going to kick up the value by that the
corollary to the theorem I'd well it's
not exactly a corollary it takes more
proof but the optimal value of C is
actually 0 that is to say the greedy
strategy beats all of the UCB terms
upper confidence bound learning so the
greedy strategy does a lot better this
is a different kind of greedy strategy
this is list price 849 they're charging
10 49 and you save minus two dollars we
calculate some small sample properties
of this so that is to say everything I
just told you is a limit theorem we can
also calculate small sample properties
those are kind of complicated but it
comes out if we can just going to skip
through this if we calibrate it either
to search and what search it's kind of a
1-percent click rate is a pretty normal
number versus display where the click
rate is one-tenth the search click rate
that is to say it's on the order of one
in a thousand and then this is also
having to introduce the notation but
this is a something that is satisfied
empirically but at me and it also is an
assumption it turns out the gains for
active exploration that is the optimal
exploration or one-tenth of a percent
that's actually what's found in practice
are pretty close to it or one one
thousandth of a percent for display
which means it's getting that right is
is almost impossible okay so the main
points I want to make summary don't
think about what ad to run think about
what to bid into an exchange this is to
say the first thing is pivot the way you
think about active exploration from okay
I'm going to choose the ad know you're
going to choose what to bid and let the
and let the bid determine whether the ad
runs that has an important implication
because what it says is explore when
it's cheap to explore don't explore when
it's really expensive if I've got an ad
that's phenomenally valuable and I've
got another ad I would like to explore I
shouldn't explore this time I should
wait until some other time you get a
fair bit of a free exploration out of
exchange for exchanges by the way
everything I told you is true about
discounting it turns out if you take the
limit as discounting goes to zero and
instead what I do is the maximum it's
the maximum average value that is the
undiscounted value then then then the
results actually instead of being k to
the fourth will be k squared so it's a
limit cases are very different in that
case but discounting is a fact of life
so discounting is the right answer to
this usually if you're a machine learner
and you see a rare feature you say aha
let's explore that here the reverse is
true rare features are bad to explore
why why do I explore rare features it's
because the fact that they're rare means
I don't get to learn about them very
often the fact that I don't get to learn
about them very often means if I want to
learn that is if the goal is learning
explore now because you don't get very
many chances flip that on its head
though and say what am I how am I going
to use the stuff that I've learned well
if it's rare it's going to be a really
long time before I get to use it because
it's rare doesn't appear very often as a
consequence what I learned isn't as
valuable you should actually explore the
frequent features not the rare features
the standard fix exploration period is
very close to optimal this is what
everybody uses and it turns out that's
what they should use and so like I said
this journey for me was to start out
saying this is crazy only to learn in
fact this is the right thing to do and
finally
exploration itself may not be worth the
effort okay in the specific case of
auctions of logistic regression so I've
got parameters on the features first
only explore negative features if I've
got if I've overestimated a feature if
I've got a strongly positive coefficient
it's going to run it's going to appear
in auctions and eventually run it's only
when it's got a negative coefficient
that it may never run in which case I
don't actually get to see it in practice
because so explore only the negative
ones that cuts in half by the way your
whole burden of exploration explore only
what a small boost gets the add to run
that is add a little bit like five
percent to the to the to those to those
features and see if it gets them to run
so explore when it's cheap and sometimes
you can do that just with the logs and
do a counterfactual analysis with the
logs to say what would have happened
okay so the bottom line is exchanged
contact just looks very different from
the usual machine learning context and
it gives very different answers you know
you've spoken too long when people quit
looking at their watch and start shaking
it only that doesn't matter with this
kind of watch shaking it doesn't make it
work better whereas taking it off and
banging it on the table probably does
and with that I'm done
how so already is a kind of subsidy to
do add because we're very new ads using
the features that work for the existing
Adam there's a survivorship bias and he
has a show and here you're treating the
new ads on the same cases of those that
yeah actually you get what anyway the 40
so we are subsidizing learning a bit
right so that not not only that you get
advertisers with really crummy ads
leaving the system changing their name
and coming back as a new ad and just
running them over and over again and
that's true even if you don't learn I
mean even if you don't have a subsidy
for them that even if all you're doing
is saying I've got a certain amount of
ignorance about them that I that I don't
take into account and so and a company
i'll remain name nameless but it's not
Microsoft and it's not google we had
sales people telling advertisers to do
this that is to say colluding with their
advertisers against the company other
questions yes let's actually that's the
question that I wanted to ask so to
amplify on that i I've heard some at
platt phones say that they don't do any
explore exploit explore exploit
trade-off because they're worried about
the gaming though that would then cause
on the advertiser side so I guess you're
told maybe ended up saying that we
should we don't need to do much of it
anyway but so so actually let me say two
things that are hope that could be hold
that you've you've brought up one is
there are there are definitely
advertisers themselves doing a certain
amount of exploration and they can do
that by the same mechanism i just
described of increasing their bid and
and you see especially advertisers who
have contracted with search engine
managers to help them doing a lot of
active exploration that is moving their
bids daily throughout the day where
eighty percent will be at a certain
price i'll give it for a give
and the other twenty percent will vary a
fair bit where so they seem to be doing
so there's a lot of also free
exploration that we've just set aside
we've made the advertisers passive in
this process but the advertisers
themselves have an incentive to do it on
the other point that you made yes I've
heard this point I don't actually and I
agree active exploration makes that
point worse but if I'm only doing a
little bit of Acts active explore first
that exists even under the greedy
strategy that is to say advertisers
might gain the system in the way that I
that I already mentioned which is if
your ad doesn't perform very well leave
the system and come back in as a new
advertiser this makes that slightly
worse right but that that that already
exists the techniques used to stop it
which is to basically recognize the
advertiser and stop them from doing this
which by the way it can be as simple as
using it is this the same credit card
because they're often small advertisers
and they don't have access to a whole
lot of credit cards that problem exists
we make it a little bit worse but just
marginally worse so I don't think of
that as being too serious a problem
whereas I think of the fact that the
advertisers are doing their own
exploration it may be that there's
really no reason to do any exploration
that you're getting enough from the
advertisers themselves that's an
overwhelming advantage later than you
mentioned that's one issue how much of
the value you can extract from the
advertisers and so you don't probably
really think that they have serially
uncorrelated for every auction and so
they have persistent videos you might
want to use some kind of dynamic
mechanism where you are extracting
something up front because you really
screen them based on the initial
information so you said it is you know
you say
we'll get them in New York for the
experimentation problem as well how why
wouldn't that be used right so let me
agree that I think it's not used just
because it's complicated and and we
don't have what I think of as clear
direction of what we should be doing
dynamically I completely agree that the
the advert so so when they do these
predictions you actually have advertiser
specific effects so if it's a automobile
ad or a lipstick ad or whatever there
are characteristics of the ad you have
characteristics of the page it's on it
could be a news page or a movie page or
what have you and it could and then you
also have characteristics of the user so
the user can be male or female and so on
all three of those go in the one that's
reasonably can be reasonably viewed as
independent across time is probably the
user characteristics but even then there
might be some correlation but those
might be reasonably independent many of
the other features that you're learning
about are almost surely correlated
especially at the ad level so that is in
particular if I look at a specific ad an
autumn a Toyota ad it's the the
advertisers its up against will be
correlated with the ad characteristics
itself by the way the theory allows for
that that isn't a problem for the theory
because the theory starts with the
Toyota ad and just says the other
advertisers are a draw but it could be
correlated with the Toyota ad that's not
ruled out there are treated as
independent of each other okay that's
not even necessary because all we need
is the distribution of the best one but
needs to be random there needs to be
some randomness there may not be or not
be very much in which case that would be
a defect of the theory if you've got a
pointer to something that tells me how
to do better dynamics I'm actually
pretty interested in I haven't really
been following that literature recently
okay thank you